Administration officials say everything
is under control here's National
Security adviser Jake Sullivan
we do have estimates of how many
encounters there are at the border we
have believed that that system uh is a
system that does an effective job of
being able to determine who is coming
across the border and what the right way
to deal with their cases are there
National concernity concerns over the
title 42 expiration we are taking steps
to be able to manage the expiration of
title 42 and to put in place a process
that will be orderly and Humane and we
believe that in doing so we can protect
our national security concerns
he better be right
the cover of the New York Post today
reads Rush Hour
thousands wait as border will throw wide
be thrown wide open in just eight days
the editorial board writes most of the
people crossing should not qualify for
it but Biden lets them in anyway giano
Caldwell Fox News political analyst Jose
Aristo Nuno former DNC Deputy press
secretary gentlemen this is going to be
a lightning round let's hit it first
with you Jose if you can even approach
defending what this Administration is
doing right now as our agents are seeing
a tick up in suicides they're overrun at
the border
look at it look it's a it's a tough
issue just last week uh they they they
caught 1.5 million pills of fentanyl at
the Border in Nogales um Arizona so the
border patrols of this Administration
they're doing their jobs but if we want
to do a better job a faster job we got
to make sure that we pass some sort of
Border enhancement there's a bill right
now in Congress we should get a pass the
president's budget 2023 it's got
hundreds of millions of dollars for
Border enhancement if Republicans really
care here it's about immigration well
let's get let's put more resources on
the ground let's stop finger pointing is
that you know but Jose and again we got
to keep it quick American issue you know
giano that the problem isn't just poor
money on this you got to slow down the
surge I mean can you imagine 18 000
people is projected a day coming over
when title 42 goes away in eight days
insanity and what our colleague bill
malusian just showed us is a complete
dereliction of Duty by Joe Biden himself
you want to talk about what his policies
have done just fiscal year 2020 E2 we
saw 2.7 that we know of million people
come over here the year the fiscal year
before that 1.7 million that we know of
so a year later you have a million more
people not to mention over a hundred
people on the terror watch list that
have been caught that we know of this is
uh this is a bipartisan issue it should
be a bipartisan issue but it takes a
president who's willing to acknowledge
that this is a major problem is not
simply a challenge this is something
that is impact in the lives millions of
people not only that for the first time
in our country's history in a 12-month
period we've seen over a hundred
thousand Americans who have overdosed
from the use of a drug So for anybody to
say anything outside of this is
something that we need to work on
immediately is gaslighting and lying to
us uh gentlemen I got to let you go but
when we come back together again let's
talk about title 42 because you know
they don't have they could move that
date the White House could do that maybe
they'll do the right thing and they'll
push it back so we can stem this tide
while we catch up and maybe spend some
of those resources to hire more people
judges good to see you both hey everyone
I'm Emily compagno catch me and my
co-host Harris Faulkner and Kaylee
mcineny on outnumbered every weekday at
12 p.m Eastern or set your DVR also
don't forget to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page for daily highlights